fast fünf Monate Krieg in der Ukraine
und auch heute wollen wir uns die
militärische Situation im Land ansehen
und diese entwickelt sich ja man muss
sagen schon sehr eigenartig denn auf der
einen Seite haben wir hier im Osten des
Landes die Offensive Russlands die seit
fast einer Woche überhaupt nicht mehr
vorangeht das heißt nachdem man die
Region luhans hier im Osten erobert hat
versucht man eben weiter die Region
donetts zu erobern die wir hier sind vor
allem die Stadt slowensk und wir können
das nochmal auf der anderen Karte zeigen
auch die Stadt kann man Thorsten die
direkt daneben liegt jedoch kommt
Russland hier überhaupt nicht mehr voran
das heißt seit über einer Woche haben
wir sozusagen ein Einfrieren der Front
und kein russischen Vorsprung mehr was
die Russen natürlich extrem ärgert warum
ist das so weil die Ukraine mittlerweile
Nacht für Nacht die großen russischen
Waffenlager zerstören wir sehen hier aus
der aus der Stadt stachern auf in der
letzten Nacht in der Region luhansk ein
brennendes Waffenlager und wir können
uns das einfach mal ansehen wie dort die
verschiedenen Raketen immer wieder
rausgeschleudert kommen hier sehen wir
es zum Beispiel das sind Raketen große
Raketen also die dort gelagert wurden
die eigentlich gegen ukrainische
Stellung oder ukrainische eingesetzt
werden sollten aber dort verbrennen und
wir sehen uns die Situation noch heute
morgen an wie so aussieht und wir sehen
das auch auf Stunden später wir lassen
das einfach mal laufen auch Stunden
später heute morgen dieses Waffenlager
weiter an brennt und wir sehen auf was
für eine riesige Rauchentwicklung das
ist das hier sind mehrgestöckige Häuser
also Hochhäuser wie osteuropäischen
Bauart und dort sehen wir den Rauch
gleichzeitig ist es auch so dass dort wo
Russland irgendwie an eine Front
gekommen ist werden jetzt Frontstellung
gebaut das heißt diese klassischen
Gräben und auch die wir sehen es hier
werden von der ukrainischen Arterie
angegriffen hier haben wir einen
kamas-lkw der russischen Armee der einen
122 mm mörserlager hier versorgen wollte
an der Front aber auch der wurde
entdeckt von der ukrainischen von
ukrainischen Drohnen und dementsprechend
dann von der
präzisionsartillerie westlicher Bauart
angegriffen und hier zerstört was heißt
das Ganze für den Krieg in der Ukraine
das heißt Putin kommt nicht mehr voran
und Putin ist extrem wütend darüber und
deshalb haben wir gesehen wie er gestern
hier in der Region winitzer dieses
Freizeitzentrum für ukrainische Soldaten
angegriffen hat dort 22 Menschen getötet
hat darunter
mindestens drei Kinder und heute
Nikolajew angreift auch im Mücke live
gibt es nicht direkt eine Front man
sieht das jetzt hier nicht genau aber
eigentlich ist es ungefähr 30 km weg von
der Front und auch dort greift er weiter
an und wir sehen jetzt hier von heute
morgen den Beschuss dort wurden
verschiedene mindestens zehn Kaliber
Marsch verkörper abgeschlossen auf die
Stadt und wir sehen uns das noch mal
hier ein bisschen weiter an wie das
aussieht wir haben auch dort natürlich
große Rauchentwicklung und auch dort
greift er und das ist schon
bemerkenswert keine militärische
Infrastruktur an sondern er greift
Wohngebäude an er greift eine
Universität an er greift Schulen an er
greift an Hotel an und wir sehen das am
Ende dieses Videos
und in verschiedenen in verschiedenen
Aufnahmen und das ist eben schon ganz
ganz beeindruckend wenn man so möchte
weil er eben nicht mehr militärisch
vorankommt an der Front sich nicht mehr
bewegen kann von den westlichen Waffen
dort wieder zurückgehalten wird greift
er Städte weit im Hinterland der Ukraine
an und dort offenbar völlig willkürlich
hier sehen wir ein Hotel in Mücke live
was getroffen wurde heute was hier
schwer zerstört wurde das sind die
ersten Bilder die Feuerwehr hier noch im
Einsatz und als zweites sehen wir die
Universität der Stadt die Universität
von Mücke live die auch hier schwere
Explosionen abbekommen hat nach einer
Schule gestern heute also die
Universität des Landes der Stadt die
hier von russischen Raketen getroffen
wird es ist also überhaupt nicht klar
was Russland hier noch genau möchte man
kommt im Osten des Landes nicht weiter
voran die Front dort verhärtet sich mehr
und mehr ohne dass die Ukraine bisher in
der Lage wären zurückzuschlagen also
erweitert Putin den Krieg auf das
gesamte Land greift also Städte und
Menschen weit hinter der Front an und ja
weiter so seine Kampagne des Terrors
gegen die Ukraine weiter aus